ça
t merde
excuse-moi
recommencez
l'hélico on a l'ombre à gauche ah merde
autant pour moi allez je recommence je
reprenne du champ attends
coupe comment
la faise qui est à gauche du cadre après
je crois qu'il a encore les bateau
ou
qu'on l'échappe qu'on s'en ser ouis on
s'en sert enementement
vertical il se passe pas grand chose sur
l'eau les enfants non pour l'instant
c'est
super oua c'est joli ça
ouais
ouais les Roché à gauche c'est vachement
beau
là non il les il les a pas il les a pas
il les a pas là oui mais il peut il y à
l'ombre ah ouais donc ça on peut rien
faire les enfants là to il va fallu non
ça va pas là ok attention à l'horizon
oui l'ombre est juste juste dans l'ombre
ouais ouais non mais il l'a pas le CH
ouais mais c'est toi la vue elle est pas
là tu vois elle est pas comme çait qu'on
le bien
l'arrive tu pche à droite
ouais
[Musique]
ok tu peux
couper